[Music]
Jerry must be able to see Rick is in
here but still decides to touch this
head bucket thing as if he's unaware
that Rick has inverted people he likes
far more for doing far less I asked Jean
if he borrowed my rake and he said no
like like that like too fast I think he
has my rake single brain cell that Jerry
found as a child and forced into his ear
hole is obviously busy measuring its
nasal cavity with a power drill right
now if Jerry for one second thinks this
is something Rick would ever help him
with but if I had your bra if you had my
I am so sick of this born smart Rick
swaps their minds in reaction to Jerry's
comments so why is one of the brain
strainers already hooked up and ready to
go and the second one is on his
workbench as if he was already tinkering
with it feels kind of weird that Rick is
always prepared to do a Freaky Friday so
we're swapping bodies no that would be
Freaky Friday Rick and Morty episode
mentions the thing they're riffing off
so they don't get accused of ripping off
said thing as if we care about such
distinctions and to show this hilarious
yes that sounds like a sin removal but
it is not I'm going to put my mind in
your brain and your mind in my brain
look I'm stunned that Rick is wasting a
single Nan trying to teach Jerry
something but doing it in a way that
requires Rick to be in Jerry's mind
feels like potty training a kid by
shoting in your own pants medical
emergency detected the medical emergency
bot isn't programmed with the ability to
predict medical emergencies before they
happen in any other show that would be
an unfair expectation but Rick turned
himself into a pickle one time and that
really moved the bar on what's plausible
Jerry your mind did that to my body
using my brain Jerry my mind was in this
brain in your body pretty easy to follow
it is not and the show knows that which
means the show knows that I know that
and I know that the show knows that I'll
know that and not be able to unknow it
and therefore be distracted enough to
pretend I don't know it right engage
castration protocol right now castration
protocols Society am I really about to
die because you watched a Freaky Friday
calm down Morty Hollywood's been
botching Freaky Friday for decades and
no one has died you just find little
pieces of your soul slowly eroding away
over time covering a whole bunch of
Murder by making the murderes nameless
crime aliens and setting said murdering
to the White Stripes hey get up here
said the throat to the hand things my
throat has never said to a hand Chuck
survives this you cone-headed son of a
[__] can't believe that worked I wish
they did that in the movie we all do
Rick SL Jerry we all
do they made us stop at every drive-thru
chain in the galaxies so they can make
one giant burger and they did but then
they decided to immediately discard it
and just eat a regular siiz burger
instead this show is fing weird now I'm
really curious what the remaining 13%
thinks this rake actually is it's a
shame those guys had to become us to be
happy episode wants me to believe that
if you combine Rick and Jerry you'd end
up with an extremely content and
well-rounded person instead of a
self-doubting overconfident genius
dumbass with delusions of grandeur and
impostor syndrome or a regular ass Human
as they're more commonly
known you were in a tree really gambled
on this Escape Route Rick Ary would be
jixin to TV SS so they just stick
burgers in dead guys mouths now in dead
criminals mouths summer you're defending
them I didn't take that as a defense as
much as a factually accurate description
of a character based on the available
facts irritating b-plot filler girl I
should be thanking you for making me
Rich wait I I didn't pay you for this
yeah these guys did these guys who timed
their entrance perfectly with this
reveal even though they couldn't have
known this conversation was even
happening I got something you might want
to hear I mean I guess Rick and Jerry
could just believe chuckle about the
screams belonging to Beth and the kids
but there's no way they could know that
for sure from those muffled screams
Jerry Grandpa Jesus Christ the show
making me believe that Jesus Christ was
actually a possibility here in the
ensuing disappointment when there was no
Jesus Christ holy sh all the positive
aspects of each perfectly melted
together in other words Rick and Morty
went full- on tuix and you never go
full- on tuix honestly you shouldn't
even go half tux or really anying tuix
just noing tuix I am jicky okay this is
immediately raising some biological red
flags for me like if the Jerry head eats
something does it pass through the Rick
head's skull why did they choose to keep
pants but make Jerry's arm legs naked
and why if given the option would you
use the human centipede as your
inspiration instead of
Voltron I know the chains are slightly
wobbling but Beth summer and Morty
should still be sup right now instead of
Saved I knew this day would come what
day the day that a genius slw of
evolution hybrid would steal all of your
drugs snort them and then return to kill
you after you held his family hostage
that is some very specific foresight you
have there my friend do you not hear the
Symphony of Adams dying in space no
thank you I don't want to be alone with
my own thoughts skip I have modified the
house defenses they will ensure the mob
never bothers you again we've seen this
house fight off all sorts of craziness
was a group of aliens inspired by the
mafia really a threat that required an
upgrade what was the adjustment a
hotline to the alien IRS that was a
solid alcapone tax evasion joke just go
watch The Untouchables I thought when
you came to rescue us you learned to
love us more than ever
you learned the opposite assuming that
someone leaving means they don't love
you people can love you deeply and still
want to be very far away from you and
never want to see you and generally want
nothing to do with you at all that's
totally normal please tell me that's
normal tell me that's normal I am jick
and I only need to love myself I mean
I'm as shocked as anyone Rick hasn't
invented something for that ability but
I can tell you there's at least a 99.87%
chance that the newly formed jicky is
too tall to properly love himself you
can't actually be leaving right
expecting me to sacrifice my precious
cares on whether or not Jerry and Ricky
are coming or going when it's a only
episode 2 B multiverses exist and C this
isn't even the Rick and Jerry we started
with honestly I'd barely blink if they
changed voice actors you guys don't give
a goddamn [__] about Jean preach and yet
ironically or otherwise the show keeps
wasting precious minutes on him both of
you walking out on Mom I thought you had
two sets of balls not zero assuming the
scope of your genitals has anything to
do with the quality of your character
quick tackle
this wow you're just going to skip over
how Beth summer and Morty managed to
science the out of separating Rick and
Jerry just going to straight up not
write that scene huh just going to hope
we all won't question it and that we'll
eventually be distracted by something at
the B where's all the cutlery why are
they only using forks and where's theing
orange juice coffee and condiments well
those horses won't sew themselves up
saying this with an earshot of a man you
know could make this happen and put you
out of a job shoting on The Simpsons by
giving them a room in Jerry's brain as a
cameo eight years after they gave you an
entire couch gag I could be reaching
there but if it starts an allout
multiversal war between the Simpsons and
Rick and Morty I think it's kind of
worth
it seriously I'm not even sure it that's
meat please State the nature of the
don't bother it doesn't matter Rick the
guys is already kissing your ass you
clearly don't know who you're talking to
so let me clue you in I am not in danger
Skyler I am the danger what are we
Walter White whoever you are you're in
Rick's body use your implant shut up
Wesley I got a boot my cabbages forget
it Burger it's our calling card we're
the sticky Bandits I have a a hole in my
stomach
8:58 first time I've ever been early for
work